bonsoir
vous vous retrouvez dans ce
portraits
mais celui-là n'est pas plus mauvais que
d'autres alors il y a une mauvaise
plaisanterie qui court depuis des années
dans les couloirs du PS on dit que
François Mitterrand va laisser le PS
dans lequel il l'a trouvé en entrant
c'est-à-dire en gros à 5 % à l'époque
glorieuse ou Gaston de fer faisait 5% au
présidentiel en 69 je vous l'avais dit
vous-même c'est une mauvaise
plaisanterie bon je crois que ça fait
partie de ces phrases dans Paris raffole
et qui affole Paris aussi mais qui ne
correspond pas la réalité François
Mitterrand a fait à son époque ce qu'il
avait à faire à nous de faire ce que
nous avons à faire sans aller chercher
des responsabilités dans les générations
antérieures ou chez d'autres
est-ce que le PS est encore sauvable
mais je pense que le Parti socialiste a
de l'avenir un grand avenir parce que
compte tenu de ce qui se passe dans le
monde où nous vivons sur le plan
économique social politique
les salariés les exclus beaucoup de
catégories sociales ont intérêt dans ce
pays comme dans les voisins d'ailleurs
ce qui est un parti socialiste fort pour
les défendre non seulement pour les
défendre d'ailleurs mais aussi pour
faire leur faire des propositions qui
soient acceptables et c'est ça mon
objectif mon objectif c'est d'abord de
reconquérir de l'électorat socialiste ce
sera pas facile ce sera difficile mais
j'y suis tout à fait résolué déterminé
quelque chose qui est très frappant dans
les enquêtes affinées qu'on a fait après
l'élection européenne c'est que le
message de gauche notamment auprès des
jeunes passe apparemment beaucoup mieux
quand il vient de chez Bernard Tapie
alors pour vous Bernard Tapie question
très précises pestiféré ou alliés
écoutez moi je j'ai pas à faire
d'épithète ou à dire si les pestiférés
ou étaient alliés moi je connais le MRG
quand à Bernard j'ai eu bien l'occasion
de m'exprimer sur lui je ne pense pas
avoir revenir sur ce que j'ai dit c'est
à dire non mais soyons précis
je me souviens parfaitement quand
Bernard Tapie rentre au gouvernement je
n'étais pas d'accord je l'ai fait savoir
j'ai fait savoir un certain nombre de
fois mon désaccord avec eux certains
styles et surtout certaines mélanges
mais c'est pas le sujet peut-être je
crois que les gens qui sont dans la
difficulté
s'intéressent d'abord à leurs
difficultés et pas à mon opinion sur
Bernard Tapie c'est vrai c'est pas le
sujet mais quelqu'un qui pèse 12% c'est
c'est vous serez bien un jour confronté
avec ce problème mais on pèse et puis
après on ne pèse plus on repète vous
savez moi pendant trois ans ma demande
et chaque interview commencer par que
faites-vous des 15% des écologistes bon
alors je ne dis pas que les 12% de
Bernard Tapie vont fondre mais je dis
que moi je sais ce que j'ai à faire je
vais essayer de le faire ce ne sera pas
facile et c'est ça qui m'importe plutôt
que de porter des jugements sur les uns
ou sur les autres sur leur score ce que
je sais c'est que le Parti socialiste a
fait un mauvais score et ce que je crois
profondément c'est que quelque part
c'est de sa faute on pourrait on
pourrait intitulé un peu ce qui se passe
au PS on parodie on le titre d'un film
célèbre recherche de leur de leur
désespérément vous vous êtes plutôt pour
qu'on écrive d'abord le scénario avant
de s'occuper du casting oui parce que
j'entendais que je n'avais pas dit ceci
ou cela moi je n'ai pas de candidat au
présidentiel
je lis partout aujourd'hui que tout cela
serait une combinaison non j'ai dit et
je pense et je ferai en sorte que le
candidat des socialistes aux
présidentielles soit désignés le plus
tard possible pensez bien que je ne veux
pas en rayer la productivité de la
droite en matière de candidats ils ont
produit à peu près un par semaine donc
je pense que nous avons intérêt à leur
laisser le champ libre le plus longtemps
possible et quand toutes ces fleurs
auront poussé n'est pas sur le terreau
de droite alors les socialistes auront à
choisir la leur et vous vous êtes
résolument pour une ligne de gauche or
vous savez très bien mieux que moi avec
une présidentielle le contour ça se
gagne au centre c'est à dire quand il
faut rassembler donc si on est trop à
gauche on fait un Posco au premier tour
et après on s'en va oui vous savez sur
ces positionnements moi je pense que le
Parti socialiste plutôt que de dire de
gauche de droite je pense que le Parti
socialiste doit avoir une position
antagoniste par rapport à ce qui est
l'évolution actuelle c'est-à-dire le
libéralisme économique ce n'est au
capitalisme la mondialisation de
l'économie les délocalisation la montée
du chômage l'exclusion et c'est par
rapport à ce phénomène là qu'il doit se
situer à la limite ça m'intéresse
beaucoup plus que de savoir qui portera
les couleurs du Parti socialiste mais ça
m'intéresse aussi de savoir qu'il est
portera je n'ai pas de candidat pour
l'instant ce sont les socialistes qui le
choisiront pas moins dans un instant
nous retrouverons en direct de l'île
quelqu’un dont on parle beaucoup dans
les couloirs du PS